we go now let's go into the draft first
pick right that's in a bad way you're up
i'm up oh okay go i guess i have to go
with lamar jackson i mean i think that
would be the goats and the bad way
leader this week for me for what he did
you know in the game against pittsburgh
listen there was a lot of positives but
yes he made three fatal mistakes in the
football game that cost their team
at least 17 points maybe 21 i mean he
gave them you know the pick six a short
field for another touchdown and then
they were in the red zone on a second
down and he got strip sack fumbled to
where it's a chip shot field goal but
maybe they scored a touchdown on the
next play
so lamar jackson i think's got to be the
leader in the clubhouse for me this week
last week i waited until the last pick
to
include the guy with the egregious act
on the field this week i'm leading off
with javon williams the bears receiver
who was suspended two games yesterday
for
punching cj gardner-johnson twice listen
what are you thinking first of all it's
an inappropriate act in any setting what
are you doing punching a guy with his
helmet on you're gonna break your hand
and get yourself suspended so javon wims
go to the week for me yeah uh i i get
that um all right
next one i'm going to go to here is i'm
going to go to the refs i am i'm
including that with
the past interference play we saw last
night
the past interference call from the
green bay packers game that was picked
up in that moment
you know a similar almost exact play
with the chargers and the broncos except
that was called past interference and
they left that be
i mean it's almost it's almost the same
type of thing as the other two plays and
then here's two others that really
bother me you know this really bothers
me with the refs and the nfl's got to
fix this because this is an issue
lamar jackson
first drive of the game on the sidelines
he's running the ball
somebody's tackling him he's still three
feet from the sideline
cam hayward comes in and crushes him
like you're supposed to do in the sport
of football
and they threw a late hit flag he wasn't
out of bounds he still was in the field
of play as the most dangerous ball
carrier maybe in the league so that's
that drives me crazy
later on in the day russell wilson runs
for a first down when they're trying to
run out the clock and he fakes goes down
for a slide
and then starts to run again
and then slides and gets hit by jimmy
ward that's some bs the nfl needs to
rectify that that's it's cheating i
don't even know what anyone say you're
letting the quarterbacks cheat right now
and i'm getting to the point where i'm
telling you i'm defensive coordinator
i'm just going so what hit them as hard
as you can screw the 15 yards these
quarterbacks want to do this type of
crap and start flopping and do that
screw it bring it to them and i i'm dead
serious i think we're getting to that
point to where defensive coaches might
just go we're going to get the penalty
anyways we might as well make it count
just so the record is clear that's me
chris sims right here christopher
davidson no spleen thank god this is the
turbo draft yeah if i don't know how
long you would have gone on if it wasn't
the turbo draft next one for me
look i i'm i'm i'll go i was gonna go
cam newton or bill belichick but you
know what bill belichick i i
just because i reject that explanation
he's making excuses he's the mad
scientist that's supposed to have this
team ready to go they've lost four games
in a row bill belichick all right who's
next okay my next one then and andy
kicked the onside kick god you got me to
friend that's the main thing that was
the bad one stupid on side kick
i'll go sean mcveigh or you know what
not mcveigh i'm gonna go jared goff my
last one jared goff you know some of
those blitzes
the obvious he was outnumbered
you know two fumbles and an interception
with the same exact blitz and just
inexcusable for a guy that's played that
much football that was a that was the
reason they lost that game
all right you know what he's either one
of the best players of the week or one
of the worst players of the week baker
mayfield this is your goat week next
week you'll be sunday surprise this week
here at goat i mean it's just not
nothing uninspired just
it's not sustainable it's and you know
what the br who knows let's see what
happens over the next nine ten games
they may be looking for another
quarterback next year if this continues
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports